is it possible to change careers at 30  yes you are morally obligated to change  your career at 30 please do not do the  same thing your whole life unless you  really really love it like i do with  comedy you need to do a lot of different  things don't just do one thing with your  life like a [ __ ] giraffe you're meant  for more than that you're meant to  pursue your hobbies and passions no  matter where they take you and your life  should be lived around that and not  around having stability and safety like  a [ __ ] cow  take a risk even though in this country  we don't treat people who fall out of  the system very well  it's gonna be hard  but you should do it